i just think fat free meant the fat
inside came free and sugar-free the same
thing sugar does for free everything
else it charges us for apparently yeah
i was a wild kid apparently
how's your boy still o'brien here are
some of my favorite snacks let's get to
it
[Music]
oh
first up we got the okie doke hot cheese
popcorn
let's take me back to the west side of
chicago
oh yeah
that's that's fresh that just came up a
plane for
hmm sure here right there is it okie
doker okie dokie i never knew yeah the
regular cheese ain't never hidden from
me i don't know if it's a um cultural
thing for many years with hot stuff
flaming hots uh hot okie dokie i don't
just eat the regular cheese i don't eat
the regular cheetos i like spicy stuff
though i'm a habanero ghost pepper
either you know what i'm saying don't
get me on hot ones one day
oh okay these are every day is for me
doritos cool ranch my favorites my
favorite
but i remember
going from doritos not nacho cheese to
regular nacho cheese to when this came
out man you felt like it was a remix
but they had got pd in there somewhere
uh nacho cheese is just like
it's great but it's like regular it's
like ordering nachos with just cheese on
them that's not my movies i want luxury
this is luxury right here
boom next up we got the little bites
party cake muffins i'm fatty oh my god i
inhaled these like these four of these
in the back you know they might as well
just make it one i feel better about
myself because they just made the four
into one of the little cupcake
what they put forward here you feel
really bad about yourself
they're so soft
and moist how they get it like that all
right trap that in the bag they gotta
put like some kind of
water or mildew in the background i'm
gonna keep it that much how is that even
possible
that is delicious
i should just ate one but here we are
we got some lifesavers wild berries
these is like universal you can get
these anywhere i did not know
that like you know if you're muslim or
something you probably don't eat gelatin
because it's got pork enzymes didn't
know all of that so i offered my friends
about some of my friends be like nah fam
you know don't mess we mess with the
pork and i know i was eating swine but
it's so divine i promise it is
it is
this is delicious
these forever
like the regular colors that weren't
cool but when these came out
again
it was it for me
oh you know what berry that is all right
here strawberry red raspberry blackberry
black raspberry white grape cherry and
berry man
i'm happy they just don't say like
you're red cause you know sometimes you
just say the flavor is red and you can
taste the red you're like i can taste
that actually
how big got real no fruits with that
maybe like it's real even though i know
it's
was ready for it
got me a bow
next up we got a simple cutie
i eat these all the time i'm not sure
that the way i eat them is okay i eat
them two or three at a time that can't
be good that's like eating regular
orange i guess and yeah it's just so
easy to eat
this one was definitely kept at room
temp i like my kids a little colder
complex i ain't no problems with y'all
but make sure y'all putting your cuties
in the fridge it changes the whole
experience okay because there's no seeds
in them nobody knows how you can make
the keys over again if you look it up it
might be like broccoli you probably know
broccoli is man-made broccoli is
man-made y'all look up y'all fruits and
vegetables i understand what y'all put
in
kitties i'm not sure about you but
you're delicious okay um
yeah i guess i'll settle for mikey sours
because it discontinues our
when they lose a battle with z
it's one letter we couldn't just include
z again i'd be lying if i said he's my
favorite but they are very close mine
was ours mike and ike says they're
discontinued since 2020 so i'm gonna let
y'all be i'm gonna try these right here
in front of y'all
i mean my dad used to use his hours
together all the time you know
that was our connection
now y'all infringing on that
all right mike
all right
y'all might have me again
i'm rocking with these
gluten free fat free not sure how as a
kid i just think fat free meant the fat
inside came free and sugar-free the same
thing sugars for free everything else he
charges us for apparently yeah
i was a wild kid
get you some micronics for real that was
amazing
that's all i got
i was gonna catch some more snacks man i
was ready
all right guys that's it for snack
that's my favorite snacks um if you get
a chance to get around listening to el
dorado excursions out on patty's day so
i guess it's out now
[Music]